hot breath yeah i think it's valuable
especially like younger comics to be
aware of that instinct and
really trust that instinct because even
someone
at your level is like there's something
there i don't know what
yet but you're so honed into your
process that
you know when something's tapping at
your brain of like there's something
here i just don't know what yet
that that's the direction you need to go
in i think young comics need to
listen for that instinct more and
that'll help him develop
right and actually nate actually said
something that's really great
in terms of mindset when you have
something like that you have a point a
part of it
a part of a thing that might become a
joke and um
you're working it and uh you know it's
funny but you don't have the
joke yet your mindset in terms of
mindset should be it's on the way
it's on the way i love that
i love that all right yeah it's almost
kind of like manifesting it it's on the
way
it's going to be good i just have to
figure out how to get there you know
you